ce que vous connaissez le terme
politique ce que vous savez ces quads
apolitique
la candidate libérale rencontre des
élèves syrien arrivé à montréal au cours
de la dernière année
moi je veux que le canada redevienne un
négociateur en chef de la pet l'automne
dernier sept écoles arméniennes
accueillait 18 jeunes ayant fui la
guerre ils sont maintenant 87 font
beaucoup d'efforts pour s'adapter mais
ils sont très très heureux surtout de
pouvoir aller à l'école c'est vrai ça
merci en cours de français mélanie joly
présente à la directrice les engagements
libéraux envers les réfugiés en
accueillir 25 mille le plus tôt possible
et verser 100 millions aux provinces
pour faciliter leur intégration
madame joly prend promet des millions de
dollars alors on s'y attend justement
votre fort probablement dans ce quartier
vivent 60% des habitants sont nés à
l'étranger ou au moins un parent né à
l'extérieur
beaucoup d'haïtiens d'algériens et
d'arabes du moyen orient dont doutent
les libanais on vote pour les libéraux
charles abou jaoude coiffes des
libanaises et syriennes ici depuis 25
ans selon lui leur vote ni pucek qui
nous libérons ont besoin de changement
mariage
ces 52 je ne savais plus chez les
libéraux pour vous malheureusement non
non
l'investiture libérale retardé pour
favoriser mélanie joly au détriment des
autres candidats tous issus des
communautés immigrantes a laissé des
traces
pourquoi il ya la guerre aux deux autres
syndicats je suis très inquiète quand
vous allez voter pour qui pour qui c'est
une question très important maintenant
on pose la question pour qui cette
question mais mon opinion à moi je
trouve je vais donner la chance à madame
maria mourani d'origine libanaise
maria mourani et député ici depuis 19
ans le bloc québécois l'a exclu du
caucus
quand elle s'est opposée à la charte des
valeurs du gouvernement marois elle se
présente maintenant comme néo démocrates
elle nous a trahis j'ai voté pour elle
tout le temps plein je suis fâché parce
qu'elle nous a trahis
or que voulez vous c'est sûr qu'il ya
des gens qui n'ont pas compris pourquoi
je suis parti et cetera
mais je rencontre aussi beaucoup de
souverainistes qui me le dise il me dit
je suis souverainiste
vous êtes ma députée ça fait neuf ans
fait un excellent travail
on va voter pour vous c'est la vente
trottoir ce jour là sur la rue fleury
juste à côté du kiosque de madame
mourani celui d'écologistes qui
s'opposent au projet de pipeline énergie
est c'est lui qui est rire que de
polluer 250 pour douvres
oué mais cette militante demande
pourquoi le npd ne s'opposent pas
clairement ou pipeline nous en faisait
on a été très clair à d'études
environnementales crédit pas de pipeline
un peu plus loin sur la rue fleury
le candidat du bloc québécois échange
avec une haïtienne qui lui pose des
questions sur l'indépendance du québec
comment vous comptez pour vendre ce
projet à des gens comme nous de nouveaux
arrivants on veut voir véronique québec
à l'international
mais là justement on détient pas ces
moyens là ce dernier mandat harper le
ministre des relations internationales à
ce moment est unilingue anglais et que
dit-il ou souverainistes qui pourraient
bouder le bloc dans le but de défaire le
gouvernement harper ne lisez pas des
députés fédéralistes c'est sûr qu'ils
vont se battre contre si un référendum
éventuellement si le mp2 et des idées
beaucoup en avance il va vraiment voir
certains souverainistes est hanté par
les néo démocrates mais il juge que les
engagements de thomas mulcair demeure
trop floue la plupart des candidats
n'ont pas encore dit comment il compte
créer des emplois dans le comté ni
combien le chômage ici dépasse 11% et
aucun investissement aucun emploi créé
dans ses quartiers depuis neuf ans et en
ce sens là moi je suis très critique
directe de la députée en place désolé
c'est pas vrai si je prends par exemple
la section qu'elle parle chabanel si on
prend avec des justes avec le programme
développement économique canada
on a développé entre 2011 et 2013 la
1000 au dessus de 1000 emplois maria
mourani a été élu trois fois avec de
faibles majorité elle s'attend à une
autre lutte très serrée et se prépare à
se coucher très tard le 19 octobre
ici sophie langlois radio canada
montréal